How are you, buddy?
-I'm great, I'm great.
I've been --
I have a question for you.
How many people do you think
have peyronie's disease.
-What's the disease?
-Peyronie's disease.
-Peyronie's? Yeah, I don't know.
-Have you seen ads?
-I don't think I have seen
the peyronie's disease ads.
-I've seen -- I would say I see
an ad for it maybe every hour.
-Okay.
-I don't know if anyone --
Does anyone else watch golf?
[ Laughter ]
But it's a disease
I never knew existed.
-Okay.
-And they're very
high-budget commercials.
Makes me believe it's an issue.
-Yeah.
-And it's basically an issue
where your penis has a very
dramatic angle to it.
-You're being serious right now.
You watch --
The Golf Channel has multiple
peyronie's disease ads.
-It's just, like,
single packs of Viagra
and peyronie's disease.
-Okay, got you.
-And they demonstrate it
with a giant, like, an eggplant
that has a bend in it
or, like, a full squash
but it has a weird thing.
-Wow!
-And I'm looking at it,
thinking, "What's --
Is this even a drug?
This is like a little rubber
mallet that someone --
-Do you think you're supposed
to eat the squash?
-I feel like it's -- if that's
your issue, you're good.
Like, it's not -- if you have an
eggplant, you don't need a drug.
It's just like
a pat on the back.
Like, "Get out there, buddy.
Have fun."
-But it must be --
it must affect golf.
That seems to be the thing.
Maybe it's like some --
it throws off your swing
if it's too severe.
-Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
If you have too big a dog leg.
[ Laughter ]
And it makes you go left.
[ Laughter continues ]
Anyway, that was
on my mind backstage,
but I can come back in
and start again.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's not like --
You don't have
that much else going on.
So I understand why peyronie's
would be the first thing
we talk about.
-The first thing.
-You had a baby.
Congratulations.
-Yes. Thank you.
-You had a baby boy.
-Yes.
-Cosmo.
-Thank you. Yes.
-Little baby Cosmo.
-Cosmo is a great name.
I was very happy to hear it.
I think it, like, fits very well
with you and Scarlett.
I think a Cosmo is just gonna
be perfect for the family.
But how did you
come up with the name?
-We were just assigned it
at the hospital.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-That's a thing now?
-Yeah, people --
I think the hospitals now
are just so overwhelmed
that when the baby comes out,
they're just like,
"Uh, that's Frank. Go."
You know, whatever.
'Cause they're just --
I mean, so many people now
are coming in, of course,
as you know,
with the peyronie's disease.
[ Laughter ]
And so the hospitals are --
-Do you think --
Can I ask you a question?
-Yeah.
-Do you think de Blasio should
have locked down New York
because of peyronie's?
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, at some point,
businesses have to open up.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
They gotta get back out there.
-No matter how bad
the bend is --
They're always like --
They're "flatten the bend."
That's what they said.
-"Flatten the bend."
Yeah, that's --
Could we --
We could get that
trending tonight.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know who I ask about --
Who does your trends?
-What?
I don't think anybody.
-Okay, all right, all right.
-But that would be nice
to trend --
"Flatten the bend."
-Yeah.
-But -- so, baby Cosmo.
And now, it is a unique name.
How did your family react?
-My family
is very supportive, always.
My mom, I would say,
was slightly thrown by it
and didn't quite understand it.
I don't know if she thought it
was kind of, like,
a hippy thing, but she --
You know, a dirty hippy.
[ Laughter ]
-That would be a nightmare.
-So negative.
But I --
She would call us and say --
you know, like,
after three or four days,
She'd be like, "Cosmo."
She'd be like,
"And now, is it final?"
[ Laughter ]
"Like, did you submit
the birth certificate?"
And we're like, "Oh, yeah,
we did that at the hospital,"
and she's like,
"Okay. Interesting.
'Cause I was reading
that there's also a name
Cosimo, with an I.
So that
could also be an option."
Maybe you --"
-She preferred Cosimo?
-She was like,
"Maybe you call him Cosimo,
but then, you know,
that's his real name,
but then,
you could call him still Cosmo."
-What was the upside of Cosimo?
-I don't know.
I don't know.
Because we live --
You know,
she lives in Staten Island.
Eventually, she started
meeting various members
of the Italian community who
have a lot of Cosmo relatives.
And so then, she would call,
and she would say,
"I met someone. They said
their uncle's name is Cosmo."
[ Laughter ]
"So it is okay."
-I was like, "It's locked in."
Then she goes, "There's also
a patron saint called Cosmos.
So that's another option."
[ Laughter ]
"We don't need more worse
options, variants on Cosmo,
but thanks, Mom."
-Now it's officially Cosmo.
-But now we did lock it in.
-And you are going --
This is very exciting.
This will be the first picture
anyone has seen.
-Oh, yeah.
We haven't shown anyone
a photo --
-I'm gonna put it over there.
-Yeah, he's a very,
very cute guy, and --
-Now, when did you
get this picture?
'Cause I'm always fascinated.
Like --
-I think this is probably
either the day he was born
or the first day home.
-Okay, gotcha.
All right, let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-And some --
And the hair is coming in great.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's --
-I love that you --
You know,
that thing about babies,
where you can't even tell
if they're like a boy or a girl.
-Right, yeah.
We get that a lot.
"Is it she? Is it..."
[ Laughter ]
And we're like, "No, it's --"
-I see a lot of Scarlett.
-It is -- I hate saying that,
but I do feel like I lost it,
and it's mostly Scarlett.
You know,
I want to see myself, but...
-Yeah.
-It's hard.
-Did we talk about
your friendship with Che?
You guys have a nice history
of giving each other
bad gifts
as a show of affection.
Did he give you a baby gift?
-He, I would say --
was a more mature Che.
-Okay.
-He got us a onesie.
A couple onesies.
-That's very useful, yeah.
-Very practical, useful gift,
which was nice.
He said,
"I'm sending you a onesie."
And then,
this was the onesie that he --
-We got this one,
#DaddyIsOverParty.
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
-And #CancelDad.
[ Laughter ]
-Cancel Dad.
Yeah. Um...
So that was really fun
to have your child wearing.
-Well, let's --
And remember, it looks --
-Oh, yeah,
that's the completed look.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
The face
really matches the hashtag.
-It's like --
Well, he is like,
"What did Dad just say?"
[ Laughter ]
-He --
It's so funny now.
Anything good that happens
in life, like having a baby,
half the people --
Like, I posted --
you know, posted a thing
about we had a baby.
Half the comments are,
"Oh, my God, congrats,"
and half are "Cancel Jost."
[ Laughter ]
Because Che just gets
#CancelJost, like, trending,
and then the people
who are saying congrats,
then someone's like #CancelJost,
and the first person's like,
"Why did -- Why?!
What happened?
What did I miss?"
So he's a great friend.
-He's a good friend.
-He's a great friend.
-If you're lucky
to have him by your side.